Dann haben wir hier nochmal ein paar Fachbegriffe. Zuladung, Gesamtfluggewicht und Flächenbelastung.
Flächenbelastung ist wichtig, um zu wissen, wie das Flugverhalten eures Schirms sein wird.
Wenn man einen Schirm höher beladen macht, dann wird er viel schneller und wendiger.
Wenn man ihn eher tiefer beladen macht, also mit 3 kg pro Quadratmeter, wir rechnen immer in Kilogramm pro Quadratmeter,
dann wird der Schirm viel langsamer und träger und auch weniger anspruchsvoll zum Fliegen.
Und je nachdem, welche Ansprüche man hat, kann man dann eben auch Flächenbelastung wählen.
Jedoch ist es meistens auch vom Hersteller genau so definiert und empfohlen,
dass man zwischen dem und dem Abfluggewicht halt die Grösse nimmt und dann ergibt sich eigentlich dann die Flächenbelastung.
Die berechnet man in der Regel nicht selber.
Aber wenn man in einer Zwischengrösse ist, vom Gewicht her, gleich zwischen zwei Grössen,
und nicht so sicher ist, welchen Schirm man wählen soll,
dann ist man natürlich mit dem grösseren Schirm eher etwas langsamer unterwegs
und mit dem kleineren Schirm eher etwas sportlicher, was dann aber auch ein höheres Können verlangt.
Flächenbelastung ist immer das Gesamtfluggewicht, geteilt durch die projizierte Fläche.
Beim Gesamtfluggewicht müsst ihr aufpassen, dass das nicht die Zuladung ist, das ist nicht das Gleiche.
Also die Zuladung ist eigentlich alles ausser den Schirm, also alles, was an einen Gleitschirm hängt.
Bei der Flächenbelastung müsst ihr aber den Schirm einberechnen.
Also der Schirm, obwohl der dort oben ja selbstständig fliegt, der zählt auch zu der Flächenbelastung Kilo pro Quadratmeter.
Und am einfachsten ist es, wenn ihr eigentlich mit dem Rucksack, mit eurer ganzen Flugausrüstung,
mit dem Sandwich, mit dem Getränk, mit den Wanderschuhen, alles was nachher in diesem Paket in der Luft ist,
auf die Waage steht und dann habt ihr euer Gesamtfluggewicht.
Dann kommen wir jetzt zu der Gleitzahl.
Ein interessantes Thema, wird auch immer am Startplatz so ein bisschen thematisiert.
Ja, was hat dein Schirm für eine Gleitzahl?
Und ist immer schwierig.
Die Hersteller lehnen sich da auch nicht allzu fest aus dem Fenster,
weil es kommt schlussendlich natürlich auch viel mehr darauf an, wie man fliegt und wie man das Potenzial aus dem Schirm rausholt.
Weil meistens in der gleichen Schirmklasse sind die Schirme so ähnlich, in so einem kleinen Bereich unterschiedlich, was die Gleitzahl anbelangt,
dass es viel wichtiger ist, wie ein Handling ist und wie man sich wohl fühlt mit diesem Schirm,
als dass man jetzt diesen Schirm hat, welcher er hat noch eine halbe mehr Gleitzahl.
Aber was ist eine Gleitzahl überhaupt?
Eine Gleitzahl ist ein Verhältnis euer vertikaler Distanz,
Vertikal habe ich gleich alliance, sorry,
vertikale Distanz und horizontale Distanz
und dieses Verhältnis gibt dann bei den meisten modernen Schirmen so zwischen 8 und 10.
Hochleister sind vielleicht ...
so gerne ein bisschen darüber, wie man einen Schulschirm zwischen 8 und 9 hat.
Ich habe jetzt hier im Beispiel 9 genommen.
Das heisst, mit einem Meter Höhe kommen wir 9 Meter weit.
Mit 1'000 Meter Höhe vom Startplatz zum Landeplatz könnt ihr theoretisch 9 Kilometer weit fliegen.
Und das ist natürlich ein sehr theoretischer Wert.
Da müsst ihr immer bedenken, dass ihr vielleicht einmal noch ein wenig Abwind habt,
vielleicht habt ihr Gegenwind und dann sieht das Verhältnis der Geschwindigkeiten natürlich wieder ganz anders aus.
Und wenn ich jetzt einen Flug plane, dann gehe ich meistens auch nicht vom 9. oder 10. aus,
sondern wenn ich jetzt so berechnen möchte, ja, ich mag dort vorne noch über den Wald,
dann nehme ich vielleicht eine Gleitzahl von 6 oder 5, wenn ich sogar ganz konservativ sein möchte
und nicht in ein Problem hineinlaufen werde.
Das ist die eine Möglichkeit, die Gleitzahl zu berechnen, also die Distanz, die ihr zurücklegt in beide Achsen.
Das andere ist die Geschwindigkeit.
Ihr könnt auch sagen,
mein Schirm fliegt 10 Meter pro Sekunde in den Horizontalen und verliert etwa einen Meter in der Sekunde.
Dann seid ihr auch wieder bei einer Gleitzahl von 10.
Ihr könnt aber auch ganz einfach den Auftrieb geteilt durch den Widerstand nehmen
oder den Auftriebs-Bewert geteilt durch den Widerstands-Bewert
und ihr werdet immer auf den gleichen Wert kommen, auf die Gleitzahl.
Und da seht ihr jetzt auch wieder zu dem Thema, das wir vorhin hatten,
wenn natürlich der Widerstand immer kleiner wird, bedeutet das,
wenn der Auftrieb gleich bleibt, dann bedeutet das, dass unsere Gleitzahl eben wächst und grösser wird.
Noch etwas, was ein bisschen verwirrend ist für die Theorieprüfung.
Der Gleitwinkel ist nicht gleich der Gleitzahl.
Also eine grosse Gleitzahl ist etwas Gutes.
Also wir fliegen weit.
Das heisst aber, dass der Gleitwinkel klein ist.
Und wenn die Gleitzahl kleiner ist, wie jetzt in diesem Beispiel 5,
dann ist der Gleitwinkel grösser.
Also der Gleitwinkel ist immer der, der die Horizontale ist.
Also wir können jetzt hier den Boden nehmen und unsere Flugbahn.
Und wenn die Gleitzahl besser ist, sprich grösser ist,
dann nimmt dieser Winkel immer mehr ab und wird immer kleiner.
Dann kommen wir hier zu den Geschwindigkeitspolaren.
Ist natürlich sehr theoretisch jetzt hier.
Wir haben es in der Flugpraxis schon ein bisschen gehört gehabt.
Schlussendlich muss man einfach wissen, was mache ich in welcher Situation.
Weil ihr befindet euch ja nicht immer in absoluten Nullwind-Bedingungen,
wo die ganze Luft eigentlich still steht.
Sondern wir haben Aufwind, wir haben Abwind, wir haben Gegenwind,
manchmal haben wir vielleicht Rückenwind.
Und ihr könnt euren Schirm so über die Bremse steuern und über den Beschleuniger,
dass ihr eben immer das Maximum aus dem Schirm rausholen könnt
und möglichst weit kommen könnt oder möglichst lang oben bleiben könnt.
Ich probiere jetzt in den nächsten paar Folien euch ein bisschen zu zeigen,
was eben mit diesen Punkten auf dieser Grafik passiert,
wenn wir Windeinfluss haben.
Grundsätzlich haben wir ja im Trimflug, das heisst, wenn wir die Bremse einfach sein lassen,
ist der Gleitschirm genau so gebaut, dass er eben möglichst gut gleitet.
Das heisst, wir sind im besten Gleiten.
Wir haben jetzt die rote Linie, das ist der ganze Geschwindigkeitsverlauf des Gleitschirms.
Von ganz links, vom Stall, also wenn wir dort noch mehr bremsen,
dann reisst die Strömung ab, dann sind wir zu langsam, dann haben wir nicht mehr genug Auftrieb,
der Anstellwinkel ist zu gross, wir fliegen nicht mehr.
Von dort an können wir die Bremse lösen.
Der Schirm wird schneller, er geht über.
Hier sind wir beim geringsten Sinken.
Beim geringsten Sinken ist das Verhältnis der Gleitzahl nicht ganz so gut wie beim besten Gleiten.
Wir sinken aber am wenigsten.
Schlussendlich kommt es aber immer darauf an, dass das Verhältnis möglichst gut ist
und nicht die eine oder andere Geschwindigkeit.
Dann haben wir hier wie gesagt die Trimgeschwindigkeit beim besten Gleiten
und wenn wir dann noch mehr Gas geben, wenn wir beschleunigen bis zur maximalen Geschwindigkeit,
Vmax hier angeschrieben, dann sind wir hier bei der schnellsten Geschwindigkeit.
Im Verhältnis, wenn wir jetzt hier die Zahlen herausrechnen würden,
also 13,5 geteilt durch irgendwie 1,8,
dann ist dieser Wert eben weniger gross, als wenn wir hier 10,2 geteilt durch 1,2 z.B. rechnen.
Wir müssen es jetzt nicht mit genauen Zahlen durchrechnen,
aber das Verhältnis ist immer dort am besten, wo die Tangente, die grüne Linie,
unsere Zustandskurve, also unsere Geschwindigkeitspolare berührt.
Jetzt berechnen wir mal das Ganze mit Gegenwind.
Ihr seht, bei Nullwind fängt die grüne Linie beim Nullpunkt oben an.
Wenn wir jetzt 4 m Gegenwind haben, können wir einfach die Linie weiter vorne anfangen
und so herunterzeichnen und dann sehen wir,
von dem zu dem wandern unsere Punkte weiter Richtung Maximalgeschwindigkeit.
Wenn wir noch mehr Wind haben, wie 7-8 m pro Sekunde,
dann wandern die Tangente immer weiter nach vorne
und der Punkt vom besten Gleiten ist dann eben irgendwann,
wenn wir voll im Beschleuniger stehen, beim Vollgas.
Wo das da genau ist und bei wie viel Wind, ist natürlich sehr schirmabhängig.
Also jeder Schirm ist ein bisschen anders, das kommt auf die Zuladung an.
Da sind dann ganz viele Faktoren, die man fast nicht rechnerisch herausfinden kann.
Am besten in der Praxis ist es, wenn ihr irgendein GPS-Gerät habt mit Gleitzahlberechnung.
Wenn ihr mal Gegenwind habt, könnt ihr mit dem Beschleuniger einfach mal ausprobieren.
Was passiert, wenn ich jetzt mal halb beschleunige?
Die Gleitzahl wird wahrscheinlich ein bisschen besser.
Was passiert, wenn ich voll beschleunige?
Wenn ihr dann die Gleitzahl abnehmt, geht ihr wieder ein bisschen raus aus dem Beschleuniger.
Und so könnt ihr lernen zu optimieren und herauszufinden,
bei wie viel Gegenwind muss ich wie viel Gas geben, damit ich möglichst gut gleite.
Da geht jetzt schon sehr ins Detail oder schon sehr ins Advanced-Gleitschirmfliegen hinein.
Für die Theorieprüfung sind sicher die vier Begriffe ganz wichtig,
damit ihr wisst, wann ihr beschleunigen und wann ihr anbremsen müsst.
Das eher anbremsen kommt jetzt zum Zug mit Rückenwind.
Ihr seht, hier haben wir Nullwind, hier haben wir ein bisschen Rückenwind,
hier haben wir mehr Rückenwind und der orange Punkt vom besten Gleiter,
die Tangente, wandert immer mehr hier hoch, zum geringsten Sinken.
Das geringste Sinken ist etwa so 15-20% abgebremst, leicht abgebremst,
damit ihr eben weniger sinkt.
Weil den Rückenwind, wenn wir ja positiv mitnehmen, also in diesem Rückenwindband,
wollen wir eigentlich möglichst wenig sinken.
Weil der Wind schiebt uns ja von hinten und somit haben wir automatisch eine gute Gleitzahl.
Und wir wollen eigentlich möglichst leicht oder einfach mit diesem Rückenwind mitschwimmen.
Sozusagen.
Im Aufwind passiert genau das gleiche.
Ihr seht, wenn ich hier runter gehe mit der grünen Linie,
dann rutscht der orange Punkt auch wieder näher zum geringsten Sinken.
Das heisst auch wieder ein bisschen auf Bremse gehen.
Und wenn man ganz viel Aufwind hat, kann es so gerne sein,
dass er noch weiter rüber fällt, dass wir es gerne noch mehr anbremsen müssen.
Das ist jetzt sehr, sehr theoretisch.
Weil wenn wir in einem 2-Meter-Thermikschlauch sind zum Beispiel,
kommt es auch nicht so darauf an, wie gut er gleitet.
Also ihr fliegt dann lieber einfach so, dass ihr den Schirm kontrolliert und im Griff habt,
weil ihr seid dann wahrscheinlich sowieso am Kreiseln.
Also es gibt selten, dass ihr einfach im Gradausflug einfach so 2 Meter gestiegen habt.
Gibt es schon, aber ich sage jetzt mal, es kommt eher wenig vor.
Und wenn man so stark gestiegen hat, dass eben der Punkt vom besten Gleiten so weit hinten ist,
dann ist man wahrscheinlich sowieso am Kreiselfliegen und nicht am Distanzfliegen.
Und wenn man kreisfliegt, in so einem schönen Steigen,
dann ist es auch viel wichtiger, was wir vorher schon gehört haben,
mit Gewicht zu verlagern in der Flugpraxis
und die Thermik möglichst gut zu zentrieren,
ist dann viel effizienter, als genau die richtige Bremsstellung für das beste Gleiten zu verwutschen.
Mit Abwind, im Abwind können wir auch sagen,
ein Abwind fällt, wenn man eigentlich möglichst schnell verlässt.
Gegenwind ist in der Regel etwas, das ja eher lange dauern kann.
Also wir haben jetzt einfach den Wind, der bis am Boden runter geht,
aber immer Gegenwind da ist.
Mit dem Abwind kommt noch dazu, in der Praxis findet das meistens ja nur kurzzeitig statt,
in einem Abwindfeld.
Und dort kann man grundsätzlich einfach mal sagen, einfach mal beschleunigen,
aus dem Abwindfeld rauskommen
und dazu kommt eben noch, dass auch die Gleitsalbe im Beschleunigen massiv besser wird.
Das ist eigentlich das Fazit, dass man bei Abwind und Gegenwind beschleunigt.
Wie fest das da ist, das ist sehr schirmabhängig.
Bei Aufwind und Rückenwind fliegen wir leicht.
Wenn man abbremst, könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
da ist schon ein positiver Schwung, den wir bekommen.
Wir haben Rückenwind, wir haben Aufwind.
In dieser Luftmasse wollen wir eigentlich so lange wie möglich mitschwimmen,
darum bremsen wir ein wenig ab.
Bei Gegenwind und Abwind wollen wir eigentlich wegkommen und dagegen ankämpfen,
darum geben wir ein wenig Gas.
Ganz wichtig beim Beschleunigen ist natürlich,
dass man da nur mit genug Sicherheitsabstand zum Hang macht.
Also auch wenn ihr mal eine Landung habt, wo bis am Boden aber recht viel Wind vorhanden ist,
lieber aus dem Beschleuniger rausgehen mit genug Sicherheitsreserven
und halt vielleicht stehend oder sogar rückwärts landen, wenn es den Platz erlaubt.
Wenn man alles richtig geplant hat, hat man irgendwie auch wirklich genug Platz zum Landen,
als voll beschleunigt bis am Boden weiter zu fliegen.
Weil wenn man beschleunigt fliegt, ist natürlich das Klapperrisiko erhöht
und die Reaktion vom Schirm auch heftiger.
Darum bei genügend Höhe aus dem Beschleuniger rausgehen
und dann auf eine Landung konzentrieren.
Da ist nochmal so ein wenig bildlich dargestellt von dem, was ich vorhin erzählt habe.
Wenn wir Gegenwind haben, verstärkt uns unsere Flugbahn natürlich stark.
Also der Winkel wird grösser, die Gleitzahl wird kleiner.
Wenn wir Rückenwind haben, ist es genau das Gegenteil.
Dann wird unsere Gleitzahl grösser und der Winkel wird eher flächer.
Und das ist einfach der Grund, weil wir sinken ja immer gleich schnell.
Also am Gleitschirm ist es eigentlich ziemlich egal, in welcher Luftmasse wir uns befinden.
Der muss einfach eine gewisse Geschwindigkeit, ein gewisses Sinken haben,
um diesen Auftrieb zu generieren.
Wir sinken immer, sagen wir mal, um einfach zu rechnen, mit einem Meter pro Sekunde.
Wenn wir noch mehr Gegenwind haben, dass der Gegenwind gleich stark ist wie unsere Geschwindigkeit,
den Meter sinken haben wir genau gleich.
Also das heisst, wir bleiben dann nicht stehen,
sondern wir kommen eigentlich einfach gerade runter mit einem Meter sinken pro Sekunde.
Das ist das, was man halt nicht wegbringt.
Ausser man ist in einem thermischen Schlauch oder in einem dynamischen Aufwind.
Wir reden jetzt hier von einem horizontalen Gegenwind.
Das ist dieses Beispiel.
Eigentlich, wenn es um Berechnungen geht,
spricht man physikalisch immer von Metern pro Sekunde und nicht von kmh,
weil es dann einfach einfacher geht zu rechnen,
weil die Zeiteinheiten immer in Sekunden sind.
Der Umrechnungsfaktor ist 3,6.
Also von Metern pro Sekunde in kmh ist 3,6.
Und beim Gleitschirm ist es eben noch recht gebig zum Rechnen,
weil die meisten Gleitschirme ungefähr eine Trimmgeschwindigkeit von 36 oder 35 kmh haben.
Für das Beispiel sagen wir 36 geteilt durch 3,6.
Das ergibt dann eben 10 Meter pro Sekunde.
Wir haben jetzt also einen Gleitschirm, der 10 Meter pro Sekunde nach vorne fliegt
und einen Meter pro Sekunde sinkt.
Das ergibt uns eine Gleitzahl von 10.
Ein sehr guter Schirm.
Hier erreichen wir ein Abwindfeld,
wo die Luft zusätzlich auch noch einen Meter sinkt.
Also wir bewegen uns gegenüber der Luft, sinken wir einen Meter,
aber das ganze Luftpaket sinkt jetzt auch noch einen Meter pro Sekunde ab.
Das heisst, in der Summe haben wir nachher 2 Meter sinken.
Also auf eurem Variometer wirst du da minus 2 Meter pro Sekunde.
Und das bedeutet dann eben, dass dann unsere Gleitzahl massiv abnimmt.
Das bringt dann von 10 auf 5 ab.
Weil wir fliegen dann nur noch 10 Meter nach vorne, haben aber 2 Meter sinken.
10 geteilt durch 2 ergibt dann eine Gleitzahl von 5.
Dann haben wir die Bewegungen um 3 Achsen beim Gleitschirm.
Wir haben Querachsen.
Wenn ein Gleitschirm immer so aufnickt und ein wenig nervös ist,
dann sagt man, dass er nicht so längsstabil ist,
weil er um Querachsen hin und her nickt.
Dann haben wir die Längsachsen.
Das ist das Rollen oder das Wingover-Fliegen.
Wobei das Wingover-Fliegen eine Kombination von ganz vielen Achsen ist.
Aber man sagt, die Bewegung und die Längsachsen rollen.
Und das wäre dann Querstabilität.
Wenn ein Schirm nicht so stabil geradeaus fliegt, dann ist es Querstabilität.
Und dann haben wir noch die richtige Stabilität.
Das ist die Hochachse, die eigentlich durch den Piloten durchgeht und durch den Schirm.
Bei dieser Bewegung, also wenn der Schirm immer ein wenig so macht in der Luft,
dann sagt man dann Gieren.
Man merkt auch die Stabilität.
In der Praxis ist es sicher wichtig, wenn man es mal gehört hat,
auch für die Prüfung und so,
aber vor allem jetzt auch für die Theorieprüfung,
müsst ihr einfach die Fachbegriffe kennen.
Stabil, labil und indifferent.
Wenn man ein Gleitschirm baut,
also jeder Hersteller will eigentlich,
dass man ein Gleitschirm möglichst stabil baut.
Weil wenn ein Gleitschirm stabil ist,
dann bedeutet das, dass er nach einer Störung
wieder in die Ausgangslage zurückgeht.
Also man kann sich das ein wenig vorstellen wie eine Schale.
Und wenn man da jetzt eine Kugel reingehauen lässt,
dann hört sie immer wieder am untersten Punkt aufrollen.
Und wenn man dieser wieder einen Schub gibt und sie wieder aufwärts rollt,
dann geht es ein paar Mal hin und her und irgendwann ist sie wieder in der Mitte.
Also es ist wie wenn ihr mit dem Gleitschirm geradeaus fliegt
oder beschleunigt, dann löst der Beschleuniger wieder,
der Schirm geht wieder zurück in die Ausgangslage.
Von der linken Seite, der Schirm dreht ein wenig nach rechts ab,
es pendelt zwei, drei Mal hin und her
und der Schirm fliegt wieder geradeaus.
Also ein super schönes, stabiles System,
das beim Gleitschirm auch dank dem so gut funktioniert,
weil unser Schwerpunkt so weit unten hängt.
Aber das ist eigentlich das Ziel eines Gleitschirmherstellers.
Labil könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
wie wenn ihr die Schale auf den Kopf stellt
und die Kugel oben drauf drückt.
Also da könnt ihr der Kugel einen Schub geben
und es wird eigentlich nur noch schlimmer.
Man kann ihn nie mehr selbstständig einfach wieder zurückfinden.
Er geht nur einen Huch, einen Windstoss
und sie keilt runter und wird immer schneller.
Und beim Schirm auch.
Das ist zum Beispiel ein Schirm, den man startet
und der nachher immer schneller wird
bis er einen Frontklapper bekommt.
Das sind alles so Sachen,
die man früher in der Gleitschirmentwicklung
in der Praxis feststellen musste.
Und da sind dann die Fachbegriffe dazu.
Indifferent ist dann noch,
wenn ein Schirm die Fluglage beinhaltet.
Also wenn ihr einer Kugel einen Schub gebt
auf einer geraden Fläche
und jetzt angenommen,
die hat keinen Rollwiderstand,
die rollt einfach immer weiter, einfach geradeaus.
Sie pendelt sich nicht ein, sie wird nicht schneller,
die rollt einfach geradeaus weiter.
Also wie wenn ein Schirm
eine Windböe von links überkommt
und dann anstatt, dass er
zweimal, dreimal hin und her pendelt
und wieder geradeaus fliegt,
geht er einfach in eine Kurve hinein
und behaltet die Kurve einfach bei.
Das ist der Unterschied von labil, stabil und indifferent.
Ich hoffe, dass ihr es euch vielleicht
mit diesen Schalen und diesen Kugeln
ein bisschen besser merken könnt.
Dann kommen wir noch zum Kurvenflug.
Im Kurvenflug entsteht
ein Lastenvielfaches.
Also ihr seht wieder,
vertikal ist die Gewichtskraft,
die nach unten zieht.
Wenn wir geradeaus fliegen,
haben wir 1g, also einmal
unser Körpergewicht.
Wenn wir anfangen, die Kurve zu fliegen,
dann nehmen die g-Kräfte zu.
Und man kann es berechnen
mit Winkelberechnungen,
man kann es aber auch aufzeichnen.
Und wenn ihr es aufzeichnet,
könnt ihr eigentlich heraus messen
und werdet dann feststellen,
wenn ihr hier einen 70 Grad Winkel macht,
dass die Kurvenkraft, die Fk,
bei 70 Grad
genau dreimal so lang ist
wie eure Gewichtskraft.
Und bei 60 Grad wäre es dann 2g,
also zweimal länger
und bei 45 Grad wäre es 1,4g.
Also 1,4 mal mehr
als euer eigenes Körpergewicht.
Im Kurvenflug,
da ist so eine Aussage auch von der Prüfungsfrage,
im Kurvenflug nehmen jetzt
Lastenvielfache zu,
das heisst mehr Belastung auf dem ganzen System
und die Minimalgeschwindigkeit
nimmt auch zu.
Ihr könnt es ein wenig vergleichen,
wie wenn ihr einen Schirm höher beladen würdet.
Also wenn ihr jetzt einen neuen Soloschirm
als zweiten dranhängen würdet,
hat das die gleichen Auswirkungen
aerodynamisch gesehen,
wie wenn ihr eine Kurve fliegt
von 60 Grad
und auch 2g auf dem Schirm wirkt.
Und zwar verschiebt sich eure
ganze Geschwindigkeitspolare
massiv nach vorne,
also
jedes Element dieser Polare
wird einfach schneller.
Eure Trimspeed wird schneller,
eure Maximalfluggeschwindigkeit wird schneller,
aber eben auch euer Stall
oder eure Abrissgeschwindigkeit
ist höher.
Bei dem Kurvenflug müsst ihr aufpassen,
weil eben die Strömung,
also eine schnelle, extrem schnelle
Kurve ist noch keine Garantie,
dass kein Strömungsabriss passieren kann,
weil bei höherer Flächenbelastung
braucht ihr auch mehr Geschwindigkeit,
damit die Strömung euch nicht abrisst.
Passiert in der Praxis
dann aber eher weniger,
weil wir ja auch viel höhere Stördrücke
auf der Bremse haben.
Aber trotzdem wichtig zu wissen,
dass Geschwindigkeiten alle zunehmen,
also sowohl die Mindestgeschwindigkeit,
als auch die Trimmgeschwindigkeit
von eurem Schirm,
sobald die Kräfte höher werden.
Ja, dann möchte ich mich bedanken
für eure Aufmerksamkeit
und hoffe, dass ich euch in diesem Teil
auch wieder ein wenig weiterhelfen konnte
und dass ihr jetzt motiviert
an die Theorie reingeht,
das Büchlein gut studiert,
die Fragen durchlöst
und dann erfolgreich an die Theorieprüfung gehen
und bestehen werdet.
Und dass es euch hoffentlich
auch in der Praxis
das eine oder andere ein wenig mehr Sinn macht
oder euch vielleicht
ein Lämpchen aufgegangen ist in diesem Bereich.
Vielen Dank, bis bald.